تصعيد خطير كما وصفه اكثر من مسؤول امريكي
ولكن هل هناك تفاصيل اكثر نعرفها عما حدث
تحديدا في هذه
الهجمه نعم ليلى دعينا نبدا من التطور
الابرز خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه وهو
الاجتماع الذي عقده الرئيس بايدن مع اركان
فريقه للامن القومي بحضور كبار المسؤولين
العسكريين والامني من وزير الدفاع وقائد
الاركان بالاضافه الى وزير الخارجيه مدير
السي اي اي وايضا مديره الاستخبارات
القوميه عاده في اجتماعات من هذا النوع
تعرض سيناريوات اولا تقدم اخر المعطيات
الاستخباراتيه والعسكريه المتوفره حول ما
حصل على الارض وثانيا تقدم الخيارات
للرئيس بايدن ليقوم بدرسها في سياق الرد
الذي قال انه سوف يقوم به لمحاسبه
المسؤولين بعد هذا الاجتماع صدر بيان وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن و كان لافتا
فيه اتهام قال ان المجموعات المدعومه من
ايران هي التي قامت بالهجوم ولم يتهم
ايران مباشره بالمسؤوليه هو اعتبر ان
المسؤوليه تقع على المجموعات المدعومه من
ايران وليس ايران مباشره وهذا له دلاله
حقيقه في ظل تواتر المواقف من قبل
المشرعين الجمهوريين الذين يضغطون على
اداره بايدن للرد مباشره على ايران من
ناحيه العمليات وفق مسؤول امريكي هناك
تقدم في مساله التحقيقات حول مصدر الهجوم
من اين انطلق وايضا حول طبيعه السلاح
المستخدم المسيره وتحديدا بلد المنشا
وتاكيد ان هناك مجموعه مسلحه مدعومه من
ايران هي التي قامت بشن هذا الهجوم قبل
نحو تقريبا نصف ساعه اخر معطى وصلنا من
مسؤول امريكي انه يجري تحديد هويه هذه
المجموعه وبالتالي مساله الاشاره الى انها
مجموعه مدعومه من ايران تتعلق ب بطبيعه
الحال بنوع السلاح المستخدم ولكن ايضا
هناك معطيات استخباراتيه اخرى المعطيات
تشير ايضا وفق مسؤول امريكي اخر الى ان
الاصابات بلغت نحو 30 جريحا ولكنها مرشحه
للارتفاع هذا الموقع الذي استهدف والذي
يعرف وفق التقارير علما ان حتى هذه اللحظه
لم يسمي اي مسؤول امريكي تحدثنا اليه
الموقع باسم البرج 22 لكن هذا الموقع
استحدث ابان الحرب ضد تنظيم الدوله داخل
الحدود الاردنيه ومره اخرى كما قال الرئيس
بايدن كما قال بيان القياده الوسطى كما
اكد لنا مسؤول امريكي وزير الدفاع
الامريكي اكد مره اخرى ان الهجوم وقع داخل
الاراضي الاردنيه تحديدا شمال شرق الاردن
وبالقرب من الحدود السوريه مسؤول امريكي
قال لنا ان هذا الهجوم هو تصعيد خطير ليلى
لانه حقيقه منذ بدايه الهجمات على القوات
الامريكيه في سوريا والعراق في الساب عشر
من اكتوبر والتي تجاوزت
ال151 هجوما اذا اضفنا اليها ثلاث هجمات
وقعت في ال 26 من هذا الشهر لم يسبق ان
سقط هذه هذا العدد من القوات الامريكيه
خصوصا سقوط قتلى امريكيين الهجوم الاكبر
قبل هذا الذي تعرضت له القوات الامريكيه
وقع يوم السبت من الاسبوع الفائت على
قاعده عين الاسد وحصل بصواريخ بينها
صواريخ بالستيه وادى الى اصابه اربع جنود
امريكيين باصابات دماغيه رديه وهو ما ردت
عليه الولايات المتحده بقصف داخل العراق
وبالتالي نحن ننتظر اي رد فعل اخر بالمعنى
العملياتي على ما حصل وتوفر المزيد من
المعلومات ليلى حول هويه المجموعه التي
هاجمت المكان الذي هوجم منه وطبيعه
المسيره او بلد المنشا لهذه المسيره